-Welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, it is Friday,
and it's pretty much
felt like that
since noon on Wednesday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, today, my Apple Watch
was like,
"Your heart rate
hasn't hit 200 lately.
Are you okay?"
What a difference
a few days can make, though.
Check out what the breaking news
was on CNN this morning.
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, well, today
was President Biden's
second full day in office,
and he spent it trying
to fix the economy.
This afternoon, he signed
two executive orders
meant to provide fast
economic relief.
Yep, Biden's taking on
America's biggest problems.
Yesterday, it was the pandemic.
Today, it was the economy.
Tomorrow, it's people
who don't know
the Bernie Sanders
meme is over.
"Put them in my back --"
Yeah, you missed it, man.
Some more news
out of Washington this morning.
Chuck Schumer spoke on
the Senate floor
about the impeachment
against Donald Trump,
but he had a bit of a flub.
Listen to this.
-Senators will have to decide
if they believe Donald John --
Donald John Trump incited
the erection -- insurrection
against the United States.
♪♪
-Well, someone's excited
to be Senate majority leader.
I wasn't sure how the Democrats
planned to unify the country,
but if it's with bloopers
like this, count me in.
I'm in.
Meanwhile, down in Florida,
Disney World
is making some updates since
there's now a new president.
Check it out.
-The Hall of Presidents
in Disney World
is closed
so technicians can add
an animatronic version
of President Joe Biden.
-And to keep it authentic,
the Biden robot will commute
every day on the monorail
from Delaware.
Let me just say, you can add
any president you want,
but the only robot
the kids are there to see
is William Howard Taft.
Yep, a President Biden robot,
which means everyone in the hall
will be listening like...
-Corn Pop was a bad dude.
And he ran a bunch of bad boys.
And I did --
And back in those days,
to show how things have changed,
one of the things
you had to use,
if you use pomade in your hair,
you had to wear a bathing cap.
-Okay, I'm going to go grab
Mickey ears or something.
You kids know
where we're staying, right?
You remember where
we're staying?
Good. Alright, I'm gonna leave.
You can make
your way back, right?
Okay.
"Corn Pop knew some bad dudes."
[ Laughs ]
-Dungarees.
-He knew people like
Count Chocula
and stuff like that.
Some entertainment news
was just announced,
that the release date
for the new James Bond movie,
"No Time to Die," has been
pushed back for a third time.
At this point,
they've delayed it so long,
the technology
is going to look ridiculous.
Like, "Mr. Bond,
your latest gadget
is a phone that takes pictures."
Yep, the film
has been delayed so much,
they've even had to update
the title a few times.
First, it was...
Then it was...
And now it's like...
"And then I'll
take it from there, and..."
Some business news.
Since the pandemic
has made travel difficult,
one airline has figured out
a new way to make money.
Watch this.
You can now get wine delivered
from American Airlines.
That airline has so much
leftover wine
that they're launching a new
wine-delivery subscription
for $99 a month.
-Yeah, not only that, they're
also selling the hummus pucks
that were
stuffed between the seats.
Who wants a puck?
Come on.
And, finally, I saw
that Dunkin' Donuts
is now adding salads to its menu
at select locations.
Yeah, when you order a salad
from Dunkin' Donuts,
even the workers are like,
"No, seriously,
what can I get you?"
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody!
-♪ Paragraphs slash
your phonograph in half ♪
♪ It be the legendary
back on a warpath ♪
♪ First class,
leaving mics in a cast ♪
♪ Causing ruckus like
the aftermath when it blast ♪
-What a show
we have for you tonight.
You can see her as a judge
on "Go-Big Show" on TBS.
Rosario Dawson is here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Maybe, maybe a little
Cory Booker cameo.
Just saying. Senator Booker.
Plus, he stars in the
TNT series "Snowpiercer."
Daveed Diggs is here!
And we've got great music
from Amanda Shires
featuring Jason Isbell.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, man.
-Hey.
-Good to see you.
-Yeah.
-Wow. You look good.
Did you get --
You look different.
-I took your advice.
-Is that right?
-Yeah. Last night,
I showed you the tattoo.
You said, "Hey, you got to get
the other side done," so...
-The camera -- Check out...
So...
Was it...
Well, you look upset.
Was it --
-Well, I told
you I was having --
feeling a little buyer's remorse
and you said,
"No, no, it's your Lamborghini.
You got to get
the other side done."
-Yeah.
-So, you know, and I
was having second thoughts.
Now I'm having third thoughts.
-I think it's good, man.
You got two tattoo.
-Yeah.
-Two tattoo.
-Tattoo part deux.
-Yeah.
-Look, you know what I say?
Two tat. Two tat.
Two, two, tat-tat-tat.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
Oh, man. Oh, my God.
Well, hey, if you don't
come Monday with a full...
-Yeah.
-I want, like, a crab on your
head or something like that.
With a crab,
like two claws coming down.
-You really think?
-Get sponsored -- Yeah, man.
Get sponsored by --
-See? I mean, because
I always felt like --
I don't know -- like 45
is probably the cutoff for
new face tattoos.
-Absolutely not.
No, there's no cutoff.
No, no.
That's the time to get it.
-Okay.
-Because that's the time,
I think, where your skin
kind of -- It's kind of
settled in already.
I do want to bring
up something, by the way.
This is cool
that we get to do the show.
Obviously, we're very lucky
to do this.
But we have
the best band in the world
with Tariq and The Roots.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But Kirk,
Captain Kirk Douglas,
on guitar, who's one of
the greatest
guitarists in the world,
has his own signature Gibson SG.
Look at this.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yes!
-Kirk, talk to me about this.
It just came out.
I'm excited about this.
-Thank you.
Yeah, it just came out this past
Wednesday, and this is it.
This is in Inverness Green.
-What did you put --
What are the specs
that you did, that you put in?
-Well, one of the things --
I don't know if you remember,
but a while back,
there was this artist
that was on the show, Prince,
and he broke a guitar that was
very near and dear to me.
-Really?
-Yeah.
So, that guitar
is actually in Cleveland,
at the Rock & Roll Hall of Fame.
-Is it really?
-Yeah, it is right now.
And I missed that guitar.
So when Gibson came to me
and they wanted to do
a signature guitar with me,
before I sent it down there,
I sent the
broken Prince guitar to Gibson,
and they replicated the specs
of that neck.
So while that guitar
is in Cleveland,
I have this guitar,
and when I feel this neck
of this signature guitar,
I feel the neck of the broken...
Yeah.
-The Captain Kirk Douglas SG.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-I'm so proud of you.
I love the color.
-Thank you, man.
-That's awesome, bud.
Hey, so,
during the quarantine,
you know, we were doing
the show from --
I was doing the show
from my house
and just staying in there.
And when they
finally, like, let --
They opened up essential
businesses and stuff like that,
I went to a hardware store
to get a light switch.
I was going to install
a light switch.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, I did.
And I did a good job.
-Okay.
-I know how to do it.
So, I go to this hardware store.
So, I'm in the hardware store
and I hear this song playing.
And it's so good.
I go, "What is that song?
Do I know this one?
And it was like...
♪ If you're gonna go down ♪
♪ I'm gonna go down swingin' ♪
And I go, "Oh, that's great."
So I Shazam the song.
I go -- And it's by
Thad Cockrell.
T-H-A-D Cockrell.
And it's about, like --
Anyways, it's about, like,
if I lost you...
Let me just play a little jam
of it here, 'cause it's good.
So, it's probably --
It's almost like two songs.
It's this jam. It's like...
-♪ ...I would do ♪
♪ If all we lost ♪
♪ If I lost you ♪
-So, "If I lost you," right?
And then it goes...
-♪ If I'm gonna go down ♪
♪ I want to go down swinging ♪
-So, I didn't
rock out like that,
but in my head -- I had the mask
on and everything,
and I'm just like, "Oh, this is
the jam right there, man."
So, I was maybe doing
a little of this groove
type of thing.
But then it became my anthem,
because I'm like,
"Yeah, man, this is, like --"
When you want
to give up, don't give up.
Just -- If you're going to go
down, you go down swinging, man.
-Yeah.
-So, I get into it.
This is my anthem.
I love the song.
Anyways, long story long.
Thad Cockrell --
he released this record.
No one knows
there's gonna be a pandemic.
They put all this work into
this album, and it comes out.
They have a pandemic.
Your whole plan's
pushed to the side.
So, if you go
on his Instagram,
he tells this story,
and it moved me.
Anyways, so, he writes a
whole manifesto to his manager
and says, "I got to think of
something else to do.
I think I'm going to stop.
I'll think of a different job.
I mean, I have
other things I can do.
I'm talented.
I could do something else."
So he's actually going to
to start something new.
And on January 3rd,
he sends it to his manager.
January 4th, the manager
calls him, and they they said,
"We're not going to talk about
this manifesto thing,
because we just got a phone call
from 'The Tonight Show.'"
And, yeah, he's
like, "You're going to be on
'The Tonight Show.'"
And he was like, "What?"
And he said that he cried
for an hour.
They thought the phone cut out.
He's like,
"Did the phone cut out?"
He's like, "It's just like --"
And he goes,
"It just goes to show,
don't give up,
because you never know if
Some moron is going to walk into
a hardware store
and Shazam your song."
And he is coming on our show
Tuesday, this Tuesday.
Thad Cockrell.
And he's playing with
The Roots live in studio!
That's what I'm talking about.
Oh! Go down swinging!
I love it, man.
It's so cool that we get
to do stuff like that.
Hey, everybody,
President Biden
took over this week,
and there's a lot of new faces
in his administration.
So to help you get to know them,
I thought we'd give you
a quick rundown of who they are.
It's time for "Fast Stats."
-♪ Time to do the "Fast Stats" ♪
♪ "Fast Stats" ♪
♪♪
-First...
[ Laughter ]
...we have Xavier Becerra.
Next, we have
Alejandro Mayorkas.
Next, we have Gina Raimondo.
Then it's Marty Walsh.
Next up, it's Antony Blinken.
Then we have Tom Vilsack.
And, finally, it's Janet Yellen.
This has been "Fast Stats."
-♪ Time to do the "Fast Stats" ♪
♪ "Fast Stats" ♪
♪♪